Mom, you can sit here.
He's going to watch his own performance in a minute.
In a minute, so I just like, and I like scoring it.
So you can, you can, yeah, you can.
I'll be here to comment, so just, we'll watch him tell us what he's thinking.
What I remember thinking.
So, okay.
Okay.
You can press pause here, and you can talk as much as you want.
Press play.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, like, I just say what I'm thinking about, right?
So my mind's clear right now.
I'm just thinking about the sidekicks.
Okay.
Now my mind's still clear.
Still thinking about the sidekick here.
Wasn't too great.
Now, I'm just thinking about the last little part.
Pulling hand, staying strong.
Eight second count in my head.
Just looking straight.
Now I'm just thinking about pulling hand and key up.
Okay.
And, yeah, that's pretty much it.
I didn't really think about much else.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah.
Okay.